want to get in
you can work the ipod yes
you're a nice guy jim but you have no
idea how to vacation
well now sal you know i'm still getting
over the tragedy loss of my wife
i'm such a strong female woman with nice
heavy breasts
[Music]
greg fifteen thousand dollars cash
stanley did you just come back from
burning down a rival nightclub laughing
up albert i'm in florida for a month
without my
family i'm going to enjoy this find some
kenny loggins
vlog in the museum did i say messina
i've spent so much my life telling
myself please don't end up like stanley
and now i'm wondering if i even have
what it takes
i'm very hard working yeah when you're
not totally blazed
i assure you that's not me
just be cool larry what were you going
to use the guns for
life for short drive fast leave a sexy
corpse that's one of my mottos
ruth i'm going to be straight with you i
accidentally knocked up a woman greg
florida stanley smiles florida stanley
is happy to go to work
florida stanley is who you want on your
florida team
you